kind of enjoyed wallowing in it it was
helpful
um sort of self-inflicted pain disney
characters look
effortlessly ethereal but working
16-hour days in tight costumes with
thick prosthetics isn't exactly a
magical experience behind the scenes
there were fake faces
complicated contacts and some of the
most restrictive corsets
in the world you might see these live
action scenes differently once you know
how these actors
really felt after being poked and
prodded into fairy tale perfection
once you put those things on you feel
like cruella deville
emma stone had 47 looks to wear in the
upcoming cruella movie she even had to
let makeup artists
graffiti her face but the most
challenging outfits for emma were those
which had super long trains
particularly the garbage truck dress
which had a train that was 40 feet long
it's like things you only ever imagined
and think you would actually put on your
body
and carry behind you on a garbage truck
she couldn't even move with it on so the
train had to be added to the dress
after emma climbed on the back of the
truck a scene we'll have to wait to see
in the movie if we want to know
how well she actually pulled it off for
cruella emma stone did
a lot of climbing while wearing epic
dresses this look with an incredibly
long red train
had to be worn while the actress climbed
on top of a car
pulling the skirt around the car without
it getting caught was the hardest part
and not letting the weight of the dress
pull her to the ground
co-star emma thompson gave her props for
her skill in maneuvering the heavy dress
saying she had to put it around the car
about a million times because it was so
hard to get right
every single part is so beautifully
played
to become the beast dan stevens had to
walk around on stilts and wear
a 40-pound prosthetic muscle suit
covered with visual effects indicators
that tracked his
every movement he compared the stilts to
wearing 10 inch high heels
it's an ordeal for my calf muscles alone
thankfully he wore a cooling unit under
his suit that could be plugged in
between takes so he didn't overheat
what a regrettably large head you have
i should very much like to have it it
wasn't just
cgi that made the red queen's head huge
in alice in wonderland helena bottom
carter
also had a prosthetic forehead applied
to make her head seem
larger and push back her hairline the
three-pound wig on top of her head
didn't make things
any more comfortable and costume
designer colleen atwood
outfitted her with an elizabethan dress
with a high collar
the actress's head was then digitally
enhanced to appear
three times its normal size on film but
that meant helena had to be really
careful about not bringing her hands
anywhere near her head while acting
so they wouldn't interfere with the
special effects they reminded me ever so
often that my
i was much wider than i thought ever
find yourself wishing you had a pair of
cinderella's glass slippers
well you should count yourself lucky
that you don't while the original plan
was to have lily james wear the slippers
it turns out they were much too painful
and she couldn't even get them on
it doesn't fit because it's made of
frosty crystal
real ones were designed for the film but
the slippers we see the princess
actually wear are completely cgi they're
made of glass
yes turning angelina jolie into
maleficent was a daunting task
every day it took three hours to apply
her prosthetics and later remove her
prosthetics and she had to wear them for
16
hours a day jolie insisted on their use
herself
they included teeth nose ear and cheek
pieces
once the horns go on you start to
mind you the first few days you knock
your head on everything and while
wearing them
wasn't the most comfortable thing in the
world having them applied and then
removed was by far
the most painful part of the process as
it involved a lot of poking and prodding
the actress's skin
turning johnny depp into the mad hatter
involved some complicated contacts and
crooked teeth
he was transformed by makeup artist
valley o'reilly and hair stylist terry
beliel
the orange wig and clown-like makeup was
a daunting task
but what was most uncomfortable were
these kooky contacts the actor wore
for all his scenes but depp knew exactly
what he was signing up for
since the mad hatter's look was based on
watercolors by the actor and director
tim burton oh great one who summons me
terrible one who commands me creating
the genie for aladdin meant putting will
smith in a motion capture suit the real
uncomfortable part of this costume
wasn't that it was too stiff or
restrictive
it was that it was thin and skin tight
not leaving much to the imagination
it was done this way so they could catch
the actors angles and movements
perfectly since the genie isn't
technically wearing clothes
that is actually me it's a 100
cgi character emma watson loved belle's
yellow ball gown
but it was actually a deceivingly thick
dress to wear
it was made from multiple layers of
satin organza
to add a modern look to the gown 2160
swarovski crystals were added to the top
layer of the dress
multiple copies of the dress were
created for these scenes taking over
12 000 hours to make in total i had the
big dress on he had the ridiculous beast
finger you know we were like
it was very bonding to accommodate
aladdin's running along rooftops the
design team traded pointy toe slippers
for sturdier custom-designed ankle boots
but not every one of his outfits was
made for comfort aladdin eventually has
his prince alley makeover
and has to wear copious layers of ivory
and gold
including a long cape and an oversized
turban embellished with
ostrich feathers it was sweltering in
the heat
so performing in this costume was the
least fun part of filming
no matter how good he looked did you
know that acrobatic performers have to
wear tight corsets despite all their
flips and tricks
actress eva green found that out the
hard way when she performed many of her
own aerial stunts in dumbo
she had to trade her comfortable and
flexible training outfit for a circus
outfit that was much more restrictive
and had many decorative pieces for her
to be aware of
as well as a perfectly quaffed wig
colleen atwood designed the costumes as
circus performer accurate as possible
which meant a pretty tight stiff
bodice and i was so scared of of heights
it was
real phobia and i i really panicked at
the beginning
any brunette who bleaches their hair
will know it is not
easy but for alice in wonderland actress
mia vasikovska
insisted on having her hair really
bleached to the perfect blonde instead
of just wearing a wig
she went through endless hair dyeing
sessions and touch-ups during filming
and since her hair is pinned straight
the waves had to be touched up between
almost every take the fairy godmother's
dress in cinderella was the biggest
dress
created for the movie with incredible
volume that actress helena bonham carter
was
basically swimming in so the dress was a
piece of architecture
sandy powell spared no effort designing
the costume
this costume is not like the rest
actually underneath here
is a crinoline cage which actually gives
it a silhouette there are
led lights and 10 000 swarovski crystals
hooked up to it with tiny
fine wires so helena had to be
incredibly careful with it
especially while running in some of her
scenes when it came to making maleficent
fly
a pretty simple costume addition ended
up being one of the most
challenging things for angelina jolie to
wear and perform in
the wings were cgi but jolie actually
had to wear little stumps on her back so
they could digitally add the wings
later this proved a challenge because
she had to always be sure to move as if
she had huge wings protruding from her
back
the most painful part of getting these
wings just right was the fork-like rig
she and other flying characters had to
be hooked up to when filming their
flight scenes
mulan's costume designer bina degler
knew exactly how she wanted to bring one
of the characters most
iconic looks to life but it wasn't an
easy outfit for actress liu efe to
perform in
there are multiple layers of robe
underdress panels and a sash that all
add drama and flow to the outfit
it nearly took four weeks to embroider
and 40 feet of material
it wasn't as light and easy to move in
as it seems
so actress leo efe was tasked with
making movement in the heavy costume
look
effortless that's that might be not
everyday
everyone could experience creature actor
ed
osmond had to wear a very strange suit
to become dumbo
while all we see on screen is the
incredible cgi
behind the scenes he had to wear a green
suit and crutch-like arm extensions
he was walking on all fours for about
three hours per day
proving his role in the movie was one of
the hardest to master
becoming elliot the dragon for the
live-action pete's dragon was another
daunting task that required
a huge green suit motion capture actor
eric synden had to wear a massive green
wire mesh head so it would look like the
actors
were really interacting with the dragon
sure it was heavy and bulky but the size
also made it super easy to track
and later alter with cgi we were able to
capture exactly what he was seeing
and we were going to be able to put that
back on the screen makeup artist and
designer denise kum was responsible for
mulan's
incredible matchmaking makeup but the
look was thick and made facial
expressions
challenging each stage was layered with
a mix of pigments fashion makeup and
conventional makeup and it was all
literally painted onto mulan's face
while mulan cuts her hair in the
animated version
designing hair for the live action
version was also much different
and involved applying tons of hair
pieces to leo yaffe's hair
lily james and the live-action
cinderella were in the news a lot over
reports that her waist had been
digitally shrunk in her ball gown but in
reality it was just a very tight and
painful core set
i know in this course it's really hard
to breathe it took
20 minutes to get lily in and then out
of the dress and corset which took 20
people to make and featured
10 000 swarovski crystals and 3 miles of
hems princess jasmine has more than 10
outfit changes during the film
the most painful dress naomi scott had
to wear was this royal pink number
the bodice was tight and restrictive and
it was embellished with heavy gold coins
that the actress had to be careful not
to rattle too much
or catch on anything while moving around
the most
challenging costume for emily blunt to
wear as mary poppins was this dress
while they look like they have ruffles
and fabric details it's all painted on
to blend in with the animation of the
scene which also affected the way
emily had to wear the costumes she had
to carry them as if they did have
ruffles and voluminous skirts and make
sure her movements didn't make the
dresses fall flat
turning 2d designs into a 3d dress did
you know that alice in wonderland was
the disney live-action film with the
most prosthetics to create members of
the red queens and white queens courts
120 actors were outfitted with unique
hairstyles and fake facial features
thanks for watching